hey everyone what's going on welcome to
Monday night yeah
there was never a more appropriate
t-shirt printed than this because today
we're playing alien isolation if you
haven't played this game it's horrifying
and amazing I bet Marat skis in the chat
room will Becton creeper in the corner
Jason O'Malley in the back yeah that's
right
if you've never played this game this
game is very scary
it takes place after the first Alien
movie before the second one you play
Ripley's daughter Ellen Ripley
and you don't know what happened to your
mom she's missing in action and you go
we're on a space station we're playing
actually I had to bring my PlayStation
and we're playing we're about halfway
through the game John Hurt is not in
this game but there was a cool flashback
at one point shady good to see what's up
Squasher che hatred 69 Stanley CK Ike as
'read oh my god shorty Wow wow that's a
so yeah I played this last night on my
own personal Twitter first Carey Sunday
I just had to keep playing it cuz it's
horrifying
Chewbacca's dad what's up yes we've also
redecorated
our team cocoa thing in here we did a
great acoustic performance with Kurt
Vile which will be up when it's up now
music there you go team koco.com slash
music that's will put a link to actual
performance in the chat the cool thing I
like about this game is the aesthetic is
very 80s retro which is very cool
oblivious miss what's up
yes cricket news I didn't find the
cricket in my apartment from last night
there was a whole cricket situation I
would think what are see so this game is
horrifying because you're constantly
sneaking around so this is gonna be a
little scary
what up Hines Guardian good to see you
Conan is currently is that the alien
whoa that is the alien oh my god oh my
god that's the alien so basically this
game is super scary because you don't
have a lot of weapons well the working
Joe is talking to the alien so here's
what's happening we're on a space
station the alien slash xenomorph who I
also called Gary cuz it makes me less
scared of him to like give him a name
we're hot or hot you can't kill it so
you just gotta hide I mean it has acid
for blood there it is right there oh my
god oh Jesus Christ oh Jesus no no no
please don't come over here no no no no
no please don't come over oh Jesus God
it's so scary if you're watching oh no
no no no no no no no no no no no no oh
my god
dude it's right there good god oh my god
Squasher this game is all about when to
come out of the closet yeah exactly
posters two people kissing this game is
really scary if you're watching this and
you have the ability to and you have the
ability to listen with headphones
definitely listen with headphones
because it's super freaking so this this
motion tracker lets us know where the
alien is and also where other life-forms
are now if that if that thing has red
eyes it's gonna kill us no it has white
eyes which means it won't kills this is
an Android they're called working Joe's
yeah I am lost dude alright so uh okay
hey thanks for hosting us cool tom we
appreciate that
cool Tom B's music what's up perfect fix
good to see you okay so what do we have
to do here what do we have to do see all
the creature okay right now we're trying
to like in every alien movie I don't
know why
they do this but in every Alien movie
they always try to trap the creature
somewhere and then they end up trapping
themselves in with the creature which is
freakin stupid like what are you doing
like so that's what we're doing right
now we're trying to shut all the windows
and the vents and everything in the
stairways off to trap the creature
inside this one part of the base exactly
Chewbacca's dad says don't listen with
headphones you'll be cleaning up urine
for some time seriously it's freaky
okay so oh Jesus oh I'm dead oh god oh
my god oh Jesus oh god oh no it's so
scary like this like horrified BET's
horrified oh my god dude dude dude dude
okay okay the thing is I just recently
got the flamethrower so which means like
that you can drive it away with the
flamethrower you can't kill it but you
can drive it away
all right I got the flip I just didn't
use it quick enough okay
all right wait all right let's just
figure out where we gotta go what is
Gary
everyone saying here Gary is what I call
the alien I call the I'm named an alien
Gary because it makes me less scared to
call him just gare-bear uh so yeah
Gary's been here he's because he's
murdered someone horribly Jesus is there
some place to hide Facebook down for I
feel like where is the gingerbread man
okay I'm in the server farm whoo stun
batons good cuz that helps this thing
it's also oh no Facebook hissed Facebook
is down it's weird
worldwide Facebook is down the alien is
inside the server's Gary's inside the
server's redone there's a fair amount of
people requesting lights off oh you want
to try to lower the lights let's do it
oh this is good this is exactly what I
don't need by the way let's get in this
thing oh dude there he is there he is oh
Jesus
oh god oh no I'm so scared it's so dark
I'm so scared you guys oh please don't
come over here please don't come over
here please don't come over here please
don't come over here
Oh God oh please please go away please
go away
oh Jesus God this game is so scary you
guys I could still see him by the way
flame through Facebook quantum affinity
says
all right I got to figure out where's
the lockdown thing for this this is
horrifying
remember hold your breath Chewbacca's
dad says yes at least you won't see the
urine Vasquez says yes exactly
okay here we go I could see Gary right
there oh he's coming back he's coming
back hard you know if I wished the
androids are constantly trying to kill
me I wish that they could kill the alien
that would be awesome
perfect fix it I stay home from class
today so I could actually yeah perfect
fix high-five put your hands up each
area says hey I understand is how a
flamethrower doesn't kill it it just has
it's got great skin very strong skin Oh
God oh my god I think it's right there
oh jesus oh jesus god this street money
it's just gonna be saying oh Jesus God
oh you guys at one o'clock today at one
o'clock we're gonna be showing we're
gonna be premiering a oh it's right
there there it is there it is I see you
peekaboo we're gonna be premiering a
deleted scene from the last clueless
gamer with little wing at one o'clock
and then Todd Levin writer Todd Levin is
going to come in and we're gonna answer
your questions oh my god I'm horrified
we're gonna answer your questions about
shooting clueless gamers right he's gone
let's go that's at one o'clock today all
right where am I going where am I going
left
Oh what oh god where is he someone needs
to make a compilation of reactions that
happen during this game seriously oh
Jesus it's right there oh crap oh no no
how come my thing isn't picking him up
oh this game quit being a little baby
and COO attack Gary now I can't
authority is tripping like you know oh
my god he's right behind me
oh no I'm not I'm going for it no God
come on I sprayed it with the
flamethrower oh this game is gonna take
years off my life oh my god oh hi his
pitch yes oh my god I can't do this you
guys I don't know this part by the way
to be fair is way scarier than the other
part he's like right here the whole time
all right here we go all right no more
effing around let's do it locked up
we're gonna lock down this goddamn
server farm here we go here we go here
we go okay here we go
I'm just gonna walk I'm just gonna walk
I'm gonna walk leave normal person I'm
gonna walk like a normal person gonna
check this guy great thanks pal okay you
guy was eating ketchup okay here we go
here we go
okay we're good we're good we're good oh
man dude yeah where is he is he in there
yeah kitty-kitty kitty-kitty yeah kitty
kitty kitty
yeah kitty kitty kitty
bring it Gary where you oh now he's
behind me how do you get behind me
yeah Gary where you at
bring it dude he's freaking everywhere
game over man game over
she's got check the map real quick all
right come on buddy
bring it I'm ready I'm ready
how about a little fire scarecrow so we
wants to know from You Tube
what's the scariest game you've ever
played I mean this one's pretty scary et
for Atari scary where are you where are
you
bring it yep yeah come on
yep come on mofo yeah what's up now
where's your God now xenomorph stay away
all right oh my god I just got a
lockdown this dude oh I hate the
security access tuners the worst Oh
nailed it though I'm top
okay here we go here we go here we go
here we go I can't go in there weird
gasp I'm looking for a panel on the wall
or something
flan throw a few okay this one this one
this one this one nailed it
what did you guys do to Facebook that's
asking can I get under here please
what's shot
Ricardo by the way is an Android so you
know he's a dick
How Great Escape the server hub that'll
be easy so glad I locked myself in here
with the alien up there it is there it
is there it is yeah you want some more
fire you want some more fire yeah
trading I feel yet it is kind of like a
giant game of hide-and-seek it's good to
play in little pieces I've been playing
it I think if you played through the
whole thing it would be kind of like
repetitive but it's scary I'll give it
that
Ricardo something Android Ginga Lane
well I don't know that's not what his
ex-girlfriend say a personality of a
robot okay here we go how do we get out
of here oh I love it when the map just
has a circle like good luck it's
somewhere in here and you're with the
alien that's right the chaco go go Aaron
our man pees his pants like no one else
can
well see I thought ahead that's why
we're diaper
yeah well now the alien could see me
better thanks here we go here we go here
we go okay where we going
how do we get out of here you know what
I should do is save my game how do I do
that
do I have to go back the way I came or
can I go in here
I'll take a second to search this guy
alright here we go oh man no way this is
gonna go well no way this is gonna go
well no way this is gonna go well
oh god I feel like it's closed right
it's just me being crazy
Beth Herr president this is live y'all
whoa is he just is he standing on the
cabinet I'm in the library oops turn
hundreds of turn on the DJ stream Yugi
they go oh oh sorry wrong stream
favorite cheese I've lately been in tune
with some extra sharp I do enjoy a good
parmesan I kind of like the harder
cheese's I love Parmesan cheese like a
nice big brick of Parmesan cheese save
the game hostiles nearby great yes
Oh after I saved the game I'm invincible
I could get murdered right now won't
matter by the way I probably will get
murdered oh [ __ ] I shouldn't I ran I was
done
terrible how are you I'm being chased by
an alien that's unkillable how are you
doing oh I hear some kind of dripping or
something oh Jesus God where am I
supposed to go here what oh how do I get
over there oh great down the long
hallway of death this will be fun
all right death hallway let's is it here
is it here
I hate this game I hate this game I hate
this game I hate this game
okay we're okay
just walk quickly and calmly you know
whoever made this game by the way well
done on making the levels impossible to
navigate I mean like I know you did it
on purpose because this game is totally
freaky but I just get so lost all the
time remember they're all the same
posters
oh god this is this is death in here
this is 100% death cupcake I'd like to
go into the dust please thank you
chatter on YouTube for some reason alien
verse from this is the greatest alien of
all time this alien is stupid it's a
stupid stupid oh god is it here oh it's
a guy see Ricardo you a-hole yeah no
[ __ ] yeah let's keep trapping a good
idea haven't you ever seen an alien
movie dumbass great here we go that's
good to know
oh man see am I supposed to keep going
down maybe what do you think I'd go down
still
ah man it's musics not helping
Jesus much gas everywhere
it's just the right way here we go this
is the right way gary has feelings too
short he says gary has no feelings
except the urge to kill yeah that's true
all paths life terminal illness do you
guys hear something every time I walk
past one of these vents it's horrifying
look at the view preview oh look at that
isn't that pretty
it's not pretty it's me the last thing I
ever see last thing I ever see here we
go it's just the right way no oh no no
no no sounds like something's coming out
of a vent
[Music]
you don't brindle what is brindle mean
perfect fix I want to keep going down
right am I going up or down it's just
the right way
tech support nope here we go this way
nope and this is bottom the stairs great
can't go through here right oh we can't
can we go through here no we can't can't
go through oh is that it
oh Jesus Christ oh it's definitely like
on a floor above me right ah got to go
up there okay that's gone let's go
let's walk brisk at a brisk pace and a
brisk yet not a pace that's attracting
any attention but brisk Oh God
where is it
where is it okay false alarm
I'm so freaking I'm not even kidding on
this game gets in your head bad this
game is freaky alright here we go here
we go
uh too many beeps and blacks oh come on
dude please don't shoot you're just
gonna attract Gary oh I hate this guy
well now you've done it get it get it
Gary yeah get him get him kill him yeah
thanks pal
see Gary's helpful sometimes oh yeah man
wearing yeah do I want to go that way or
I mean he's probably coming but normally
Gary returns the scene of the death
maybe not
that's me get for shooting at me Oh God
let's get for shooting at the 8th hole
oh boy
ok ok yeah great let's just go over the
alien one that's a great this is well
lit and sparse here we go
yes Oh God
oh good lord I never want to see an
elevator in where my life yeah Eureka
Gary is kicking some a today hmm
all the Martians great great book highly
recommend Gary fix that dudes face good
hey chick besides beside Aaron give me a
wave do it I'll do it for oh that's the
limb fost how cold of my hands very warm
oh yeah yeah hey task force 99 good to
see it yeah that's right oh yeah no
funding no elevators
restore power yes and a half hour if
you're just joining us
let's save the game hashtag play saves
and a half hour we are gonna show a
deleted scene for clueless gamer that'll
be kind of fun to see this is a purse
it's gonna shoot me or together you can
do it I just get my wrench out got the
old rich we're gonna show it delete even
close gamer and Todd Levin writer is
gonna come in here and we're going to
talk whose gamer answer all your
questions I guess I gotta go in this way
right
I don't know where I'm going I need to
updating that Mac weird add map at give
me that map am I supposed to kill that
person
she's pretty fine turnout should I ask
her out or murder her I think I might
have to murder her unfortunately
friendly face oh no [ __ ] wins this
game try to kill me wow she's cool
alright that's nice to see I almost
murdered her I mean I still could I know
what's this emergency override situation
[Applause]
yeah
thanks dude have fun in your little
bunker doing nothing oh yeah I don't
want this to happen I'm scared I'm
scared of this I'm scared of this oh man
come on dude alright maps liked up to my
map please
it is rare we got great fans oh you guys
what's in the box
yeah wait shut the hell up you're
blowing up my earpiece weights look at
the cool reflections though and the
water that's pretty good
let's go someone made an I hate Erin
Leigh oh yeah
it's probably my mom here we go
okay okay looking good feeling good you
guys looking good feeling good just got
to figure out where to go on what to do
here we go oh man oh Jesus
a lot of desks to hide under here and
since it's not happening now I feel like
there's gonna be a crazy run back
through this room ah there's a working
Joe I wants to kill me yep yep yep Oh
God oh Jesus oh look at that
alien butt dude dude please don't look
under here please don't look under here
please don't look under here look at
that thing man
man don't look under here don't go yeah
you guys see my iPhone I see so I'm not
supposed to get ten it's coming back
though cuz it's attracted by the noise
is the problem tickle him somebody says
throw them a bone philanthropy
dude Facebook is down this alien is
working on it it's crazy I wonder why
it's scary I'm afraid is it f Society
maybe yesterday here we go
Oh
so what am I supposed to do here oh I
see
if you break the rear thumb of his foot
the alien will lose his balance and you
won't be able to chase you good idea
you'd hump the heck out of Gary well I
don't know but that's a good idea
[Music]
yes exactly
here's the thing when the alarm goes off
Gary appears so I can't let the alarm
see me where's Gary at is he still down
here no
he's coming back though mani moves fast
Jesus
jump on his back shoot that alien ah
cream shooter here we go here we go
let's go hey pal hey can you uh
hey chopper
God Jesus plasma torch up pray required
what oh geez is he here there he is here
he is here he is come on over buddy come
on over bring it bring it [ __ ]
yeah bring it yeah come on over
yeah run away a hole all right
all right so what do I do
back don't Joe do not look she don't
look under here
why is the music getting crazier why is
he music getting crazier he's looking in
the boxes he's looking in the boxes
Gary's looking to the boxes go away Gary
I'm just making a mess now
who's gonna clean that up he's so mad Oh
disable a camera as car as they says how
do I do that how do I disable the
cameras what do I disable the disabled
these cameras at Oh down I gotta go all
the way back all the way back down this
stupid hallway
it's coming back
I gotta go back to the terminal turn out
look for panel to turn off power the box
Facebook's back bombing says uh Gary now
you're turning on the alarm Oh buddy go
away don't look up I swear to god I'll
torch you I mean Gary just have a very
nice figure
Gary probably plays tennis don't you
think
yeah I'm gonna get out of this room is
what I'm gonna do let's go
nice gams yeah Gary's gams
hashtag Gary's gams
all right I'm I need to find the panel
here there's some kind of panel
somewhere it's here this is the panel
low power uh is he coming here somehow
I gotta go this way anybody have any
idea what I should do
Oh in here maybe restore power
where is he sorry service us hey what's
up Lyon is yes Conan does come on these
streams sometimes but it's always random
is this where do I'm over here do we
were surprised
go back to the room with the camera okay
hey Nino thanks for joining us behind
the camera is the panel underneath the
camera got it
yeah the plasma torch operates under the
camera got it all right thank you
all right Gary's not around looking good
feeling good oh this is the room that
Gary's gonna about to be in so you know
what I shouldn't do is access where you
are right now this is stupid
turn off camera okay oh here we go
got that upgrade yow got that dope okay
yo
[Music]
use that plasma torch get er done get er
done
yeah yep this isn't gonna attract an
alien at all no this is totally quiet
yeah super quiet great really glad I did
that
before we do that let's go back
[Music]
only steady mr. power fine the screw
yourself
okay let's go let's go let's go dark
room dark room dark room dark room okay
here we go let's catch up on some emails
let's see if Facebook is up prescription
on the line manager eight eight nine
seven eight eight nine seven maintenance
systems
whoops was I not supposed to do that
like that might have been dumb I gotta
go back this way oh Jesus Christ that
scared me uh I need to know how to kill
his alien could you do it for me how
about turning the power back on chopper
hey some cans I could recycle those you
know just cuz there's a space station
doesn't mean you have to throw your
trash everywhere you know I once got
killed doing this so great no weights
make yourself useful Mikey says watching
this at my college library people keep
looking at me when I jump yeah well
exactly
glad you're learning something like
don't go on a space station where
there's a xenomorph okay whoa whoa is he
coming in here he's not coming in here
is he
man search the cubbyholes
hey I can go up here
well this is dumb nothing up here
hey eye tones good to see you so YouTube
says Twitter is going crazy with
Facebook down yeah
Jesus you know working Joe they should
have put a an alien killing protocol in
you you think that the company I guess
the company though wants aliens right
that's the whole point of the company to
get the xenomorph all right where we
going where we going where we going
take a left trigger the analysis lab
breaker switch okay exactly
okay we're feeling pretty good about
this Oh God like we in a wrong way
oh it's this can I go in here
I'm a new chef this will end well I was
wanting to die in a maintenance shaft oh
this is a tear this is it an awful idea
this is a really really bad idea this is
just an incredible work perfect perfect
oh man come on dude
yeah I do need to get out of here is it
coming is it coming
where is it I hear it I hear it where's
it at my thing doesn't work oh god where
is it oh god I can hear it seriously
where is it oh come on is that it down
there can you guys see down there oh
Jesus
alright let's go let's go let's go let's
go let's go let's go let's go oh it's
right behind me oh it's right behind me
my even going the right way no I'm going
the wrong way parents behind me
your line there bloom you only want to
die in a minute yeah get away
Oh Shh Oh God please I can't keep
shooting this thing the fuel is gonna go
down
wait I was here before wasn't I no it
wasn't that I remember
caris let's just do this breaker set
required worth Oh save let's save let's
save save save save hashtag please saves
here we go
Spring Break whatever you do don't save
yes thank you reverse psychology works
well okay okay okay okay here we go
I think breaker
and also you use like move maddeningly
slow energy flow initially what does
that even mean energy flow
initialization
energy flow initially initialization
happens where okay fine be that way
what's in the box
I watched seven the other day I got
obsessed with Brad Pitt just going
what's in the box what's in the box oh
cool this is horrifying up here great
perfect
okay what's in the box man all I gotta
say is guys here's something Jesus
Christ
was in the box
you guys hear that right he's moving
away from us here we go
fax us the terminal and that could
killed don't care Gemini's shut down to
seven four three they're so mean let's
get on to the table let's get into that
table oh let's back up
oh my god where is the stupid trigger
analysis lab breaker switch so for three
hey pac-man see you later at Bryson we
hear it yeah I hear it too it's really
scary what's the box
thing is there's so many weird triggers
and switches here right he's not around
alright go there's nothing up here for
us is there oh here it is wait what was
the passcode what does that say 1879 897
guys what's the code 882 to 473 no wrong
89 said I tried 1897 is that what did
somebody say fine now people are just
writing random [ __ ] oh you guys are
a-holes don't make me go across the hall
oh jeez oh jeez Oh get under the thing
guys please what's the code stop
screwing with me
you guys are the worst don't just guess
codes you guys and we're just typing
random stuff I don't know eighty so I
ate eight nine seven eight eight nine
seven somebody's saying I thought I
tried that okay
can I enter the passcode from under an
eight eight nine seven that's wrong
that's wrong
oh you guys are dicks everyone's a dumb
dick you guys are all dumb dicks I'm
going I can now I gotta go back if I get
killed because you guys gave me the
wrong code it's gonna be a problem
oh man where's that code two seven four
three doing it to seven four three there
wasn't there was another can i what was
it to seven I already forgot to seven
four three guys are the worst
that's all we got from that oh wait
there's another code to that somebody
that I can't ruin is that me or is that
the thing I almost wet myself there I
almost wet myself two for two
somebody said like 420 blazin it's a
good code right down the hall
and I noticed big holes in your brain no
kidding
at 88 97 is another cook oh there it is
come on over here come on over here
Dewey I want you to do it I want you to
do it I want you to do it I want you to
do it this quick cuz it's gonna be
pissed at me disable the camera how do I
do that
Jesus Christ where is it where is it
what's in the box oh [ __ ]
get under the table I can't get under
the table here get in the locker get in
the lock
this is scary
damn it crap alright this game is taking
years off my life oh my god oh my god
where are we yeah what was the code
again no it was it that's the wrong code
where do we go upstairs what's the box
what is that weird noise is that the
alien yeah he unboxed my god oh we're
back okay we're back I think he's like
right here by the way I love what I'm
just blundering around and then I hear
like footsteps is that me it's right
here it's in the room with us that's
gone okay - 7 4 3 I think oh I gotta go
learn the passcode f you forever
if I have to learn the passcode it
should just automatically type it in
that's not cool
- 7 4 3 ok we got it - 7 4 3 Thank You
Barnabas
I hear it I hear it coming I hate when
that happens
not a fan not a fan of the old automatic
doors just want to put that out there -
7 4 3 here we go
I can hear it I could hear Gary in the
other room hissing maybe not like the
newest episode of the Kardashians or
something
what do you got what do you think Gary
watches what do you think his favorite
like what is he binge watching on
Netflix
besides my death he's into Breaking Bad
he's catching up on episodes of Breaking
Bad yeah yeah exactly
guys in a few minutes we're gonna
continue playing alien isolation but
where's that take quick break to welcome
Todd Levin right around close gamer
we're gonna show a deleted scene from
last close game with Lil Wayne so that's
coming up in just a few minutes oh you
know what I'm changing my answer good
unbreakable kimmy schmitt hunters I'm in
the shadow right oh yeah you only
watches Battlestar Galactica
now none in the nananananana Gary stay
away
let's just stay away pal let's just stay
away let's not kill me while I'm doing
this okay Garris appreciate it pal
really appreciate it okay okay really
appreciate you just chilling out
this is a death room that I'm currently
in and they're wrong what is that noise
let's get under the thing okay okay okay
oh Jesus the faster you move from out
detective to objective the easier it
will be however you have to be quiet
Thank You Service sauce oh geez oh god
it's nice that they made the vent also
sound like the alien hissing - really
just freak me out like 110 percent Todd
love and everybody What's Up mr. lemon
come on and you sit in the middle Todd
you sit in the middle I know we're
playing we're playing some alien
isolation okay that's right Todd 11
everybody taut 11 that's right now we're
gonna take a quick break 4 million
isolation to play this game no I've
never played this one horrifying it's
horrifying it's like a slow creepy
horrifying it's a slow creepy horrifying
the worst / best kind exactly shady
fridge exactly yes all right so are you
ready to roll will so do you want to sit
on genes do you want to know but that's
right do you want to set this clip up at
all should we just roll it oh sure I'll
just I mean it's not much to set up it's
just this was a we were talking about
one of the levels in Tony Hawk which was
like a ski resort kind of thing
yeah and Lil Wayne had a story about
going skiing there we go Pedro alright
roll the clip I love this one what's in
snowing Mountain
wait a minute rhetoric yes Whistler's
have the place this is a resort this is
like Whistler or you're somewhere in
Bavaria in a way to get hot chocolate no
you don't like the snow
you're the snow one snowboarding I don't
really do it I've been taken out by some
snowboarders when I ski and I've been
taken out by snowboarders I'm not happy
about it and then I just I beat them
with my that's good yeah you should yeah
man the funny story
I'm in Colorado and it's no ski trip and
you know you got to get in the lift yeah
and to bring me to the top of the
mountain so it's me and my homie and the
guy the guide guys our instruction guy
so he's like I said when we get when we
get to the very top I'm gonna jump first
and you guys jump after you you watch
how I jump and see how I land and you
jump after I thought it was a tourist
joke you know cuz we're in the mountains
and we're really up in the mountains I
thought it was something he tell all the
tours I'm like so this thing doesn't
safely put us down when we get to the
top and he actually jumped so me and my
homie just sitting there just at the
ground like 40 feet done come on so we
have hands that's crazy and you weren't
hurt or anything no but there's an
instructor guy got hurt after no but you
landed on him yeah you gotta go holding
hands landed on the instructor I love
that very fantastic so yeah that was
like a story kind of couldn't fit into
the clueless gamer because it kind of
just didn't David it's a nice little
story by itself but it didn't really
play into I mean it's very long it was
kind of hard to cut down yeah so a lot
of people are saying they think Lil
Wayne was high but he's submitted to a
drug test before yeah we drug test every
everybody comes in yeah does it every
time
that's right that's right but yeah so
Todd is the guy who writes a bunch of
stuff
clueless gamer he takes it and molds it
in the Edit room too and like a like a
Japanese sword makes it a very fine
sharp funny piece so so yeah and just so
you guys know that part we just showed
you wasn't live Conan in Lil Wayne and
Tony Hawk are not currently here yes
they're not here they've gone on and
done their things but yeah that was a
really fun clueless gamer because it's
always fun we have celebrities come in
to do stuff and it was weird like we
went down she would tell the fist-bump
story full-weight we went on so so
obviously you know when the celebrities
get here we have to explain to them what
to do so we went down and the worst part
of it yeah no reason to explain right
exactly don't know why anybody feel like
it just makes it all weird
exactly but so we go down and first we
went and talked to Tony Hawk who came
first right very nice he brought his
some miles and we kind of chatted him we
had kind of an idea of different areas
we wanted to hit in the game and then
and then yet he kind of got it and it
was kind of interesting because he Tony
Hawk was kind of taking us through the
game he was doing what I normally do for
clueless gamer I'm being kind of the
straight man there and he totally got it
very nice he's a professional and then
we went to talk to Lil Wayne's manager
it was super cool and weirdly to me kind
of looked a little bit like JB Smoove
with glasses on that's the kind of like
thinking like I would like maybe like
his younger brother or cousin or
something about oh yeah that kind of hit
me but a very nice guy and so we talked
to him we kind of ran him through the
whole thing and then when Lil Wayne came
we went and talked to him and I was
super nervous he's a hip hop were you
nervous at all yeah I'm nervous about
anybody famous I talked to yeah yeah
yeah I mean especially someone like him
because I like his music yes yes so I
kind of you know I knew who he was and I
was kind of excited to meet him right
exactly and he's small he's little he's
low yeah and I didn't change his name to
Wayne no that's true never did that's
yeah Wow no that's too but yeah and so
he yeah we shook his hand he was really
cool we kind of ran him through the
whole thing and then we went to fist
bump him well I didn't know no yes we
finished talking to him finished talking
to him yeah and we were done I was sort
of drifting away yes like okay I guess
we're done yeah and then I looked down
and I saw that he kind of had his fist
just sort of out like this it's just
been waiting for me and I don't know how
long it had been waiting and I just kind
of was like oh crap I have to do this I
think I'm not good at that even
handshakes I'm not good at so like I saw
there and I got nervous because like how
long has been here so I did like the
most like the quickest but then you kind
of like I set it up for you yeah you
helped me out yeah really help me out
hey going around your back you had it
all worked out like scripted as a team
we came together for one good fist pump
I think the two of us let's go get pizza
somebody asked what's your favorite
clueless gamer episode I mean they're
all kind of get to me because they're
all very different they're all different
they're all very different but what
would you be what sticks out in your
mind is a fun one from the other side
because also the thing is too is we see
things we obviously are there when it
happens
and that's always interesting because
how you feel in the room a lot of times
it's kind of like taking a test and you
can go back later and be like oh wait
that that was way funnier than I thought
in the room yeah or oh this is a really
fun running gag that we didn't even
notice like while we were doing although
you're gonna pick up on that very quick
yeah yeah I usually yeah I usually can
see in the room like oh this gives us
something yeah the I mean I might I
think my favorite one is Grand Theft
Auto I didn't work on that yeah yeah
favorite one that one was Andre do
Boucher was the writer on that one yeah
I think my favorite well honestly like I
really loved how Call of Duty came
together yeah but we were shooting it I
didn't think it was gonna be that great
I didn't cause it was so there's so much
screaming and yeah the crossing the
street stuff sound was like oh my god
that's good
like how's that gonna house like that
was the one that was actually the one
thing that when it was happening I was
like this will be this will be really
like it was so irritating while it was
happening yeah that's something you have
to understand it awful that might have
been the first one I worked on and just
having no maybe assassin's creed what
sighs it's great but just having to be
in the room with him while he's [ __ ]
up that often and that consistently yeah
it would drive me crazy because I'm not
great at been competent yes and so all
that stuff that's happened with call of
duty was not that wasn't made up no you
know sucked
yes terrible it took and this is not a
joke it took 45 minutes for him to cross
the street 45 minutes of our lives
really did it really did in the room for
and he was trying like because it's
funny for like it was like watching a
dog play frog that was really funny but
I think my like I think my favorite one
to work on was Witcher yeah Witcher was
really which was a game I didn't get at
all you know when they came in I think
you felt the same way yeah it's a hugely
popular game and I know people totally
dig it but I didn't get it because when
I see games like that I'm just like this
acting stinks and it's it's very cut
which is very complicated it's really
common very deep and they be into that
one yeah it's for people who are into
that stuff it's fantastic
but if you're just trying to get into it
and kind of cramming for a test almost
or cramming for this thing it can be
very frustrating but and I have I have
like a personal like pet peeve about
games where you have to your character
has to walk up really close to ya ask
them a series of questions go there we
could but it would be tear I mean it's
like watching the ring video you'll die
seven days later exactly well that's
what we'll keep playing the game we can
keep answering questions
be present yeah press X to pay respects
that was something to like they're all
laughed when that came up there are
moments where you're just like oh this
is a great this is a great joke like
immediately you're like wow like like a
lot of times like that was the thing to
with grand theft auto like where the
stripper was giving him a lap dance and
it was just her highs are crazy
yeah it was just you know that it's just
like an amazing it's just going to be
really funny oh that's a good question
it can be really fast it can be relieved
yeah grants I thought was like the next
day this was when do we shoot that we
shot that which one we shot a no Wayne
yeah following we did for the following
movie right for the following Thursday
or Friday yeah Friday right
yeah Anna Frye I don't know a Thursday
Thursday Thursday no he's like a late
one right after the show goes for the
middle of next week yeah it was screener
for that Tuesday yeah I'm shot at
Thursday night couldn't do anything
without Thursday so Friday and then
Tuesday was when we had that show first
kind I'd say that's pretty typical
it's normally we shoot them the week
beforehand yeah yeah and then Call of
Duty was fat Grand Theft Auto and Super
Bowl or the - yeah and we'll over here
has has edited a will and O'Malley I
shot and edited 99 percent of them yeah
will has aged like 40 yes just like
being president the Superbowl room was
probably the weirdest yeah oh god about
that yeah oh you know here's an
interesting bit of trivia about the one
we did with Marshawn Lynch
yeah there's one guy in the room like
part of the hot dogs or all these guys
in the room there's one guy in the room
knows like he's that guy know that guy's
little tiny guy and I was like weird guy
and then afterwards after we shot I was
like oh I know that is that's the dude
that II from Entourage is based on yes
the real life yeah he's Gronk's manager
and he's like Mark Wahlberg's childhood
friend that's crazy
if you real life yeah yeah all right so
I'm gonna save here and I'm gonna give
this to you to take over what do i do I
don't even know how this is great so
this is so here that this takes place
are you a lady you're at your Ripley's
daughter okay I can tell I did I just
say no to save and so this takes place
after the between the first two movies
so huge fan right now a person Daniel oh
it didn't kill us I got him you killed
him whoa no no you can't you can't kill
it but I scared off all the aliens no
you there's only one in the whole game
yeah no oh yeah there's right there you
just have to hide from it yeah it's low
how many people are watching this right
now can you have all those people make
up written claims that they'll actually
watch the show okay I'm just trying to
turn on this thing I don't know exactly
know where it is all right Haley uh-huh
hipster Bruce Vilanch new t-shirt every
week it won't go away we have a lot of
future clueless gamers that we can't
talk about lined up but
how you choose them sometimes like how
am I just kind of talk about it
yeah like like for instance Witcher we
kind of chose at first we're like watch
use this one it's so it's so long and
deep and I think that the thought was
we'll choose this one because it seemed
so ridiculous and over-the-top well also
I really liked it because Conan could
actually have sex in it
yeah and that became kind of the angle
is like with that it was kind of like
well there's he's all we cos always
talks about to have sex with Larry Croft
right yeah so it was kind of like oh
well if nothing else that can be a good
angle for this clueless gamer which is
good but also like and I've talked about
this before but you know it's important
like the first time Conan sees the game
is when we show it to him in the room
yeah so because we want his honest
reactions about stuff so it's kind of up
to Todd and I had to figure out what and
we know what he's gonna kind of go for
which is cool but it needs to be enough
different things in the game where in
case he doesn't take the bait on
something then take our bait we're
talking about like he's a wild animal
then then he can there's enough
different areas that we can that don't
depend on each other right so it's like
Oh character customization could be fun
but if that doesn't go well then you
know this area where he fights these
swamp monsters could be fun you know
like it's that kind of stuff so it's
giving ourselves setting ourselves up
for me it's like oh these long pointless
conversations will be fine yes yes I'm
always looking at stuff like like I
guess I'm usually not even looking at
gameplay stuff it's just except for like
variety of gameplay right you know but
it's usually like all the things that
are quirky about a game yeah we'll see
the seem like fun to me yeah and the
thing too for us is like we're not so
much into as you guys obviously know not
so much into like oh these graphics or
this or you know it's more about kind of
like what Conan does best is look at it
from the point of view of Sony's not a
gamer so he's like oh like this is weird
that you have to do this weird hand sign
to open every door and then it's kind of
like you know where it's like to most
people it's like oh yeah that's just
what you do in the game but so I'm
trying to find
I just I have to go up the ladder is it
the idea why this somebody came Wow
why do they keep Jesus God did it kill
me
is he like one of the androids like
Lance Henriksen
yeah all right here we go you take
alright here we go so okay you move
around obviously your weapon is a
confront aggressive act
okay so r1 v @ r1
that's your motion detector that'll tell
you where they're yeah I should be
listening right and but if you have it
out the alien can oh this is bad
so go behind something oh man this is
gonna be gnarly just try to go behind a
box or something I mean boys yeah don't
I don't know wait okay I think if I okay
so just hit that motion tracker real
quick went to the r1 r1 okay yeah
probably so you can so RL l - L - L -
hold it out and then when he comes close
hit him with hit him with the right
trigger and that'll scare him away like
you do it do it oh God oh Jesus I think
you're Sol okay you're still okay but
look around get the he's right around us
somewhere goodness yelling he could be
on the ceiling
oh you went up into a vent okay Jesus
guy why are you going - cuz he he
travels around in vents and something he
just kill me he could he's just trying
to I go up yeah I go up the ladder yeah
and then and I think you have just keep
pressing up oh my god oh Jesus do the
thing that Oh God Oh
but luckily we'll start right at the
bottom of the ladder sprinting makes
noise everything makes noise like
can I just wear soft shoes yeah whatever
they have something there should be an
option just go in your socks they should
be like a powerup you hit xx no someone
asked if we'd ever upload the entire
unedited footage of a future now that
would be so boring
yeah would be it's I know it seems
exciting but it's not boring so behind
the ladders behind you
ladders behind you oh god he's around
he's around how do you is there a way to
crouch I mean you are crouched by
pressing in the are are well I don't see
him the heuristic ok good he's gone by
pressing in the are stick you crouch
slash stand up so also the other thing
is when you're near desks or lockers and
those things you can go near them and
press X and you'll hide in them or
underneath them alright so like that
locker you could hide in a few if you
wanted to think I might like to yeah
it's a good idea hold it hold it hold X
hold X okay and then oh god oh god and
then when you're in it if it comes near
you
oh Jesus now press back on that on the
Left stick to get back and then if he
comes to smell it it might you might
have to hold our L or L to or our - he
seems like he wants to smell me he's
gone away he definitely knows who is
there a game Conan was good at he was
pretty good at the wrestling game he
beat me I remember yeah because he was
mashing buttons in just okay he was
actually okay at Mortal Kombat yeah
because that's just a game that you
could just yeah jump and shoot fireballs
yeah anything I have a better yes that
requires no thought or acuity yeah
exactly
so me said never ever hide in the locker
you're wrong I love being whoever said
that
[Laughter]
look around look around he might be ba
he's behind you oh no I don't know where
he is where is he he's above me he's
above you he's behind you if he's behind
you now he's to the left
he's definitely up in the wall he's
inside the vents he's inside the vents
yeah how do I get him
no just let's just go let's just go
alright so somewhere clear this game
it's terrible try going in here
somewhere in here is where we turn off
the thing
Oh might be in here we have to query in
here before can you ask someone how to
turn off the - seven four three somebody
oh oh no [ __ ] we did this before we did
this we did this do this yeah we have to
do it again though we should do a Friday
night drinking video games create
drinking game I do do that on my own
twitch I'll go to shared hit X then go
to Gemini shut down Danny good yeah
there we go
- seven four three it makes you look at
the code before you can turn it all
right get out of here the circle and
then across the hall is where you turn
to - yeah yeah no no no a week wait go
to the right yeah you need the upgrade
where do we get the iron torch
somebody's the desk
I don't do the desk down John Preston
Preston right sticky and Jesus look Kurt
st. Lawrence - oh my god this gate by
the way on headphones this game is a bad
horror story horrifying hit accidents
horrifying the terminals down the ladder
old Dan dear we were down the ladder
where do we go
it says the terminals down the ladder
but alright we're down the ladder right
now so what
this guy's an [ __ ] there is there is
it's across the way you can have yeah
behind those boxes me someone another
gamer question they were asking which
guests you guys think Karan had the best
interactions with the close gamer guests
whoo I feel like Marshawn yeah and
Gronkowski yeah that was great Marshawn
was so nice and funny yeah everybody was
like somebody that we really didn't know
when we're gonna get because as you know
he's notoriously difficult it was on the
radio day he was on that yeah where he
had just come and just froze out all the
media that was so crazy to shoot that
thing with him and he was like even like
ran out to his car and got like hats and
stuff yeah he's mode hats and then to
then go to a bar after we're done
shooting and that was a day right he was
like I'm only here so I don't have to if
I won't get fined like he was everywhere
that was so cool that was a fun night so
where you are yes we will play
multiplayer games we played you can hit
the pad to find look at the map see it's
like we're like right on top of it it's
the green thing yet it's so it's right
on our right oh Jesus God yeah we did
play and Beth I'll put a link to it we
played halo with some guys from Silicon
Valley TJ Zak woods and Thomas
Middleditch which is really fun and yeah
Todd and I were actually talking
yesterday about another multiplayer a
gamer which could be really fun yeah I
would like to do a squad based one yeah
that'd be great
where instead we're trying to work
together as a team
exactly I'll replace aramid Jordan the
clothes gamers segments will be 10 times
funnier asking Jordan Jordan is not
super I agree with you would be way
funnier it couldn't feel any less funny
but but Jordan doesn't he's not a big
video game guy like he doesn't he won't
really come on here I don't think he
gets it I mean he really likes Star Wars
Indiana Jones but he's right there he's
right just there get
I think you could just go up to him with
the flamethrower just pop him a couple
times
all right sure let's try it it seems
fair yeah hey me no no I'm good to see
you
yes this is Todd Levin hilarious writer
on show who's answering your question to
say about clueless gamer exactly with
drugs who have him do Star Wars
Battlefront with Conan stars bad friend
would be a fun game to do yeah I have a
key can you link to the Super Bowl gamer
people are asking I'm under here guys
yeah hey guys can I get this app recur
what did the breakers even look like
they well see the thing is they're on
the sides of the thing like what thing
but they're on the sides of this column
but it won't let us do it without some
kind of flow initialization I don't know
see all right so see here's a breaker
right here so you go up to it energy
flow initialization required what does
that mean chat help us out energy flow
initialization clueless gamer started
close capers started because we in the
digital the digital team Team Coco one
of our jobs is to come up with digital
ideas and I thought it'd be funny if cuz
Conan's really smart to put him in a
situation where and he wasn't smart can
I kiss him I think he might try to grab
isn't that neck flap yeah yeah melting
yeah well why not whoa awesome I've
never done that before I wouldn't you
that's a good question look I'm gonna
search him now
Oh perfect and so we owed Jesus it's
near you so we so we pitched it and did
to Conan did to encode it's so great
because he's always like let's try it
let's try it
Oh God
and so there then you put on the show
and it kind of blew up but these guys
with Kinect games which is odd yeah at
first we thought that would be more
because it's physical yeah yeah because
he is so bad at video games we started
with connection but I think those are my
least favorite because they're so sweaty
I agree yeah I've been Minecraft we
actually found out that that him kind of
being able to exist in a world yeah gave
him more time yeah yeah minecraft was a
good one because it was kind of even
though he spent most of time spinning at
the sky strong narrative and characters
yes lots of different things to do are
interesting cuz there's just more to
talk about
yeah and there's more to kind of there
are more holes
yeah discover like I think that that's
actually my favorite thing about
clueless gamer is that I feel like Conan
as somebody who knows nothing about
videogames it doesn't play them and
doesn't even really like them yeah
always manages to hit on the things that
even people who really love videogames
kind of call [ __ ] yeah he always
finds those things wait why can I like
why can I go in this door and not know
his wax yeah like why am I talking to
this guy when the guy I need to talk to
[Laughter]
or like this my favorite was in
Assassin's Creed always like happy
conveniently-placed bales and also yeah
hitman two words ago these are good
thing this property is a lot of body
hiding trunks yeah well guys this has
been awesome thank you for joining us
for money manly thank you - Todd lemon
bluest gamer writer and hard at work on
the next couple coolest gamers thanks to
Beth will backed in Jason O'Malley did
nothing the game today was hailing
isolation we had a blast playing it was
super fun and we will see you guys next
month
[Music]
that's right see you guys later bye
you